[Musique]
j'ai toujours trouvé au tyran vivre en
famille et tout à leurs geôliers y aura
vraiment des séquences émotion parce que
je sais que les chroniqueurs ont demandé
pardon à que ce soit à des membres de
leur famille je sais que valérie une
surprise je sais pas ce que c est moi
aussi je vous ai réservé quelques
surprises ce sera tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 22 heures 40 le cac 40 est
ainsi qu il va suivre s'ils savaient
très bien merci comme en axant toute la
journée beaucoup alors mardi s'il
m'avait demandé aux chroniqueurs de
raconter leurs rêves
ouais et quand vous avez posé la
question à doc gynéco je me suis rendu
compte que vous étiez l'homme qui change
et le plus vite des motions au monde
c'est pourquoi pour elle son dernier
rêve c'est quoi non mais je peux pas
dire s'est développé un rêve de ouf et
qu elle détruit de la luxure du péché
regardez comme tout heureux le faisons
la question et comme votre monde
s'écroule quand vous entendez la réponse
non sur ip
il fallut que sur pas le péché bien
vendu est donc en septembre 2016 vous
vous dites il manque quelqu'un de très
rares cas alors logiquement vous décidé
de recruter
géraldine maillet voilà c'est que pour
moi elle est hyper sympa bernard cas
elle est toujours partant pour la r
galéjade à s'y perdre arca combat mon
psy ou via de super d'arcueil c'est bien
sûr et donc dès son arrivée elle a
vraiment voulu vite vite s'intégrer avec
une bonne stratégie que je conseille à
tout le monde
distribuer des taquets et notamment aux
patrons je passe souvent rappelé ça va
pas plaire à jean michel ça ce sont les
coups de maillet
christophe carrière ça devrait être un
peu votre style l'express importe des
loups comme ça intellectuellement
physiquement les deux bâtés l'actuel
mans comment ça va ma chérie j'ai montré
votre photo de l'empereur oui à des amis
qui sont dans la mode dans les bunkers
des agents de casting vous en trouvez
magnifique
ouais contre toute attente en fait vous
n'étiez pas l'habitude vous n'étiez pas
photogénique
vous avez un physique un peu de géo du
club et d'animation ouarzazate
j'ai envié de koh lanta
bah moi je regarde pas je fais partie
des 60 % de personnes qui regardent pas
ni votre émission koh lanta babar est
bon
ça fait maintenant trois ans qui la
gérait 404 on s'est même temps benjamin
roure ans c'est vrai et ouais et web à 6
mois ayant quatre ans et alors les fans
ne touche pas à mon poste adoré quand
vous débarquez en direct sur le plateau
d'autres émissions ouais ça on le fait
moins ici par exemple 2013 quand vous
avez eu l'idée lumineuse de demander à
frédéric lopez et samuel le bihan allait
vendre des beignets sur ces news et aidé
à l'époque et en voir que pascal praud
il veut absolument vous parler mais vous
vous en foutez vous avez un objectif
c'est vendre des beignets
[Musique]
attendez venez la javel ou rendez vous
vendez direct des beignets on va bien
venez avec moi veulent amener les
vallées animal et vanessa me leblanc et
vous créez un beignet chouchou
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'après ravi d'être interrompue
en direct mais comme il est accueillant
il veut vous présenter ses chroniqueurs
mais vous ça vous intéresse pas du tout
vous êtes tellement excitée que tout ce
que vous raconte pascal praud vous vous
en foutez complètement
[Musique]
oui c'est une dernière fois devant la
conversation même si vous êtes sur itélé
de dix minutes c'est chez vous c'est bon
changer ta vie je dois 3 0 samuel le
bihan qui jouait dans 3 0 qui joue avec
bonheur que l'on parle des mystères de
la seconde guerre mondiale
je suis
mais tout ça pousse ça pousse d'où ces
phrases série je sais que parmi les 2500
chroniqueur quand un jour un jour fait
partie de l'émission vous avez votre
petit préféré un indice un indice elle
est sortie non à vous avez changé de
préférer alors elle sortit deux ans le
père fouras vas-y s'appelle isabelle
bien sûr c'est un peu c'est la préférée
de tout le monde sait très bien depuis
2013 avait fait plus de 1000 émission
ensemble alouda rende compte elle est
sortie de l'émission vous un grand remue
l'émission ensemble parce qu'à mes ses
boucles d'oreilles sur son sort de tout
ça
vous avez une relation unique tous les
deux et ça m'a donné l'idée de créer une
prime allemand votre relation unique ça
m'a donné l'idée de créer une nouvelle
fiction 100% française ça s'appelle un
gars une grand mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
affaire et conduisent à gauche parce
qu'ils trouvaient dans mon grand temps
ils comptent direct 8 qui l'avait
remarqué qu'ils avaient moins de
voitures à gauche qui m'a toujours fait
rire c'était marley et moi j'ai pas le
permis donc merci quand même
vous avez plus de succès qu'avant je ne
suis pas oui mais je me retourne -
l'union j'arrive pas c'est très marrant
une fois de plus et ça
dans l'émission a démarré on a quasiment
tous dit que ça ne marcherait pas non
pas moi à oui mais vous vous êtes à part
mais régulière vous devez laquelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les années qu'on sache pas à ma chérie
et quand je vois les images médicales
effectivement il serait temps que je
prenne ma retraite eut été beaucoup plus
bas qu'avant
tu monte en grade au toi je te le dis à
un moment je pense que toi et moi ça va
se faire faut se dépêcher une date à
images sur les ratios petit peu peur
alors s'il vous savez que je regarde en
son nom toutes les anciennes émissions
pour vous sortir la la crème de la crème
de tmp est votre dada comme dirait eric
naulleau c'est de faire des prédictions
sur les médias mouais pas que je me suis
amusé à vérifier si certaines de vos
prévisions
elle était vraie ou pas et à mon avis je
co d'alexis à sa place j'aurais très
peur parce que vous êtes extraordinaire
il est temps de lire dans vos boules
[Musique]
à présenter un nouveau jeu sur france 2
en direct c'est l'adaptation d'un format
danois dirais qu'on est et nagui et et
le moins voulait absolument ce format
est finalement celui qui l'a vu sur
france 2 et je vous dis c'est un truc
qui va cartonner
alors si vous le livre seul contre tous
de nagui a forcé vote un carton ça n'a
pas très bien marché on va pas se voit
là ils sont arrivés derrière armageddon
sur w9
c'est vrai ces mini splatch c'est
exactement la même chose que danse avec
les stars sauf que c'est des plongeons
il ya des gens qui disent ça sent le
plongeon pour les audiences sur tf1
si vous n'êtes pas regarder ça allait
marcher donc je suis sûr que vous aviez
raison c'est obligé de vous êtes parler
de sfax le grand coudret qui a plongé en
audience à cette semaine et ce qui est
fort c'est que vous faites aussi médium
dans ce concept de l'amour badges et ben
on a discuté on est très fier c'est
sympa bon bah vous avez fait une bonne
ouais voilà c'est ça ça va casser ça va
casser 2015 et sinon vous avez un besoin
d'autre chose alors besoin d'autre chose
pourtant valérie patoche sont toujours
ensemble la preuve avec leurs photos
postées ce matin sur instagram
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]